hey youtubers it's Charlie so there's
been reports that the Carol Danvers
Captain Marvel might be featured in
Avengers age of Ultron and might even be
added to the roster by the end of the
movie so this video is gonna be a quick
breakdown of her origin story in the
comics how they might introduce her in
the movies and my top 5 Captain Marvel
stories the roster is going to be
changing between Avengers 2 an Avenger
Street regardless of who they add to the
team and who they take away we're
already getting Quicksilver and Scarlet
Witch and there have been so many
different team configurations in the
comics
not to mention spin-offs like West Coast
Avengers which I'll probably be a movie
at some point too Marvel has to start
cycling characters in and out just to
keep the stories fresh you bring in a
new character with completely unique
perspective and suddenly it's not like
the billionth movie to feature a slap
fight for an infinity gem of all the
major changes going on behind the scenes
bringing in more female protagonists is
another big priority for Marvel Carol
Danvers is just the next person on the
list after Black Widow there have been a
couple different versions of the
character first there was Carol Danvers
the Air Force pilot then there was Miss
Marvel then Captain Marvel which is who
she is right now
she even just saved Peter Quill's asked
in the last guardians of the galaxy
comic she can trade blows with Thor in
the Hulk and she has the quick wit of
Tony Stark with the soul of Captain
America she was born to be an adventure
even before she got superpowers and
she's currently flying around in space
with a cat named chewy is perfect so
here's a breakdown of her origin story
in the comics she was born into a
totally normal working-class family and
had a fairly Lisa Simpson type
upbringing meaning she was way too smart
for her family and had a terrible father
who did nothing turn her to her
abilities as a way to escape the
small-town hell closing in on her after
high school she enlisted in the Air
Force she became a pilot rose to the
rank of colonel then went on to join the
CIA in work missions with Ben Grimm and
Wolverine before they became superheroes
she even crossed paths with Black Widow
when she was still spy for the Soviet
Union sorry you can see how she's
crossing paths with people who are
already Avengers after working with the
CIA Danvers got upgraded to NASA ended
up working with Marvel the Kree Captain
Marvel during a battle with one of his
villains Danvers got exposed to alien
radiation from a super weapon she
absorbed some of Marvel the creek
captain Marvel's DNA and got superpowers
though she became half Kree
half-human if you remember earlier this
year there was a bunch of Captain Marvel
debating going on with Skye just because
of the blue alien and Tahiti essentially
she got the powers of Superman that's
basically where her power level was she
ended up changing her costume to what a
lot of people remember from the comics
fun fact Janet Van Dyne the original
wasp helped her make it in the a movie
that they're making like right now Janet
Van Dyne isn't around for god knows why
reason but hope van died and her
daughter's in it that's who Evangeline
Lilly is playing so already you could
have like an ant-man crossover with that
character and Captain Marvel so moving
along Danvers eventually joined the
Avengers after Scarlet Witch left to
have babies I know that sounds weird but
whenever Scarlet Witch came back she
joined West Coast Avengers which was a
New Avengers team started by Hawkeye at
the suggestion of the vision that's a
little bit of a tangent but there's a
rumor that they might be doing a West
Coast Avengers movie in a couple years
so Hawkeye isn't gonna die in the
Avengers age of Ultron so he'll survive
so he might go on to found that New
Avengers team so you start to see how
Marvel can start doing two Avengers
movies a year West Coast and one for
classic not that they're guaranteed to
do that but it's a possibility so back
to Danvers she was captured by this
alien race called the brute and given
super mega powers it's sort of calling
herself binary those are the powers that
she has right now that the super crazy
powers after that she ended up losing
her powers became an alcoholic got sober
then House of M happened and went
down in that alternate reality she got
repowered as Miss Marvel and realized
her full potential she was basically
like Marvel's version of Wonder Woman it
was actually pretty cool if you remember
the first Avengers movie in the Battle
of New York
she basically defended New York like
they did only she did it by herself
during the Skrull invasion the past two
years since x-men vs. Avengers she's had
her own title called Captain Marvel
where she basically took up the name
captain instead of Miss Marvel at the
suggestion of Captain America but she
just went into space just like Iron Man
did last year and she's been crossing
paths with the Guardian since then it's
been a lot of fun she even has a cat
named chewy like I said before it's
crazy she's flying around with a cat
named chewy and when you think about it
she's got the powers and the sass to
outmatch Tony Stark any day of the week
so she is a clear choice to be the next
big female character in the movies there
are rumors that Marvel is reluctant to
give her a cold start what they're
calling a cold start that just means
they're not sure
they want to give her a low-level cameo
like a soft entry into the Marvel
Universe or movie universe versus like
her own solo movie which I do think that
she's strong enough to carry so if we
don't see her in Avengers 2 it's
probably just because they're holding
her for a bigger movie or her own solo
movie I'll be sure to add updates in
future videos about the movies if we
learn any new stuff about her moving
along here at my top 5 Captain Marvel
stories number 5 Captain Marvel vs. JSON
of spartax that's right that's actually
the story that's going on right now in
the comics she basically goes up against
Peter Quill's father who's trying to
mind vibranium to fortify this Bart X
fleet for this new big war of conquest
remember I teased war Kings could be a
potential guardians to story in this
shot right here you can see her getting
ready to take on an entire fleet I
totally love how her hair makes you
think of yondu's fin which James Gunn
got yelled at for excluding from the
movie the whole storyline right now it
just makes me feel like instead of doing
Nova in the Guardians sequel they might
just incorporate Captain Marvel it would
be an opportunity for Chris Pratt to
make some sweet-ass Star Wars references
as Danvers Kat is of course named after
Chewbacca I think the only thing
preventing that is that the character
has a human origin story so they
probably gonna start her off in an
earth-based movie but moving on number 4
Earth's Mightiest Heroes I'm talking
about the cartoon Avengers Earth's
Mightiest Heroes she debuted in season 1
as Carol Danvers the Air Force pilot
they basically did her origin story
right out of the comics so if you want
like a really easy intro to the
character just watch the cartoon she
didn't become Miss Marvel until season 2
but they do a Kree story and everything
the reason I love the cartoon so much is
just because they don't get so bogged
down with practicality like the movies
ooh they just jump right into aliens
magic everything from the comics right
away then moving on number three is
Mighty Avengers that's basically just a
really important story to read in
general because supposedly the story for
Avengers 2 the movie is based on that so
it's a good Carol Danvers story and a
good story just to get you ready for
Avengers age of Ultron next number 2 War
of the marvels this was right after Dark
Reign and Dark Avengers Carol Danvers
basically kicks the crap out of
moonstone who has been posing as a fake
Miss Marvel with Norman Osborn's hammer
team but moving along with my number 1
Carol Danvers story her solo titled from
last year from 2013 it was her first
title right after x-men vs. Avengers
it's the
storyline where she takes the name
Captain Marvel most of the artwork on
tumblr you find a Carol Danvers is from
that run all the recent title she's in
are great though so I'd at least
recommend reading all those Captain
Marvel comics since x-men vs. Avengers
so for tomorrow I am working on new
Legend of Korra and a new Walking Dead
video but if you want me to do another
Marvel like unit just let me know be
sure to subscribe to get everything
there's a bunch of Doctor Who coming
this weekend there's a whole bunch of
awesome stuff but right now click here
to learn all about how a Marvel might be
completely getting rid of origin stories
in its movies and click here to learn
all about their Inhumans movie thank you
so much for watching I'll see you guys
tonight high fives